in our waking hours for much of our
lives we're granted an unwarranted
luxury a sense that we are in mortal our
organs function normally our joints give
us no pains we are focused on the next
few financial quarters in the business
dropping dead is the last thing on our
minds but this is not the case in the
early hours suddenly there's an odd
gnawing twinge in the stomach it isn't
anything major and it might pass by
tomorrow but this might also be the
start of a tumor that will fell us by
the new year also our chest feels a bit
tight when we breathe that can sometimes
be a sense of strain there was an
incident a little while back at the
airport running for the distant gate
could it have been a heart attack a
quiet one that passes largely undetected
but tears fatefully at a valve what
about the slightly odd mole on one's
back has it always been there or is it
new
spreading aggressively and malignantly
why can't we remember the name of that
really nice colleague we worked with a
few years back his reason beginning to
crumble this would be just the moment
for a stroke which will leave us half
paralyzed paramedics will urgently wheel
us along the AE corridors on a trolley
bed we'll need to have our bottom wiped
by a nurse and be fed with a tube coming
out of our nose the sheer implausibility
of being and remaining alive grows
overwhelming how is it possible that one
can keep living given everything that
might go wrong it isn't hypochondria
anymore that McCobb almost fun state of
mind you can adopt as an adolescent this
is a realistic assessment of the risks
it's the imagination correctly deployed
this present ache or twinge might not
announce the end but something will
happen the abstract possibility of death
turns at night into a concrete decisive
fact perhaps will fall off a ladder
trying to get a suitcase out of a high
up cupboard and lie on the floor for
eight hours with a broken neck blood
filling our lungs before anyone finds
our discolored limp body well maybe
we'll be lucky and it will be a quick
aneurysm on the way back from a party
celebrating a friend's birthday whatever
it will be it's getting closer
others will be deeply distressed for a
while a few people will be sad even
years later when they happen to think of
us but they'll cope it won't matter to
anyone the way it matters to us right
now we're appalled and awed by the deep
strangeness of being alive it's so
fundamentally improbable that the
delicate web of our thoughts and
feelings is being sustained by a bunch
of pulpy fragile organs
all our complicated ideas and lovely
movements of the soul depend upon tiny
mindless white blood corpuscles oxygen
molecules and the rhythmic spasms of the
sinoatrial node why does this machine
keep going why aren't we dead already
the thoughts are horrific and the full
panic may go on for half an hour or more
but as we gradually grow used to the
idea of being obliterated and forgotten
the thought of death sharpens our
resolve we have to do the important
things while we can we need to finish
our work and dare to take up new
initiatives we need to forgive more we
can let a stupid comment pass we can
give up on a feud even though the other
wronged us the visceral knowledge of our
approaching death renews our
appreciation of existence
it's incredible to be able to hear a car
accelerating in the distance it's
fascinating to have feet the pillow
feels so nice on our cheek it will be
lovely to look tomorrow at a tree or to
hear a song or bite into a fig we're
brought back to a proper sense of the
charm of things that ordinarily seem too
slight to notice but which are close to
why life is worth cherishing the Vale of
jaded familiarity is pulled back at
least for a little while
a year starts to look like a huge
privilege to have a day when nothing
much happens won't be boring it will be
a magnificent opportunity to continue to
exist
our perspective cards feature tools for
a wiser karma perspective on life they
help to restore calm and clarity even
during difficult times
you